okay guys um day one of my fitness  journey  um so i'm about to weigh myself and i'm  gonna track my weight  every single day basically until i get  to the weight i want  i try to keep it um consistent with the  time of day i weigh myself  and what i wear um just because i like  to do it in the morning because  that way you know what i ate for the day  doesn't affect it but yeah i'm just  t-shirting shorts okay  sorry i look a little ratchet right now  but  i'm trying to keep it real with you guys  okay so i get a little nervous  doing my weight on camera just because  um the manosphere can be really mean but  keep in mind i am six foot and i'm  pretty strong  so it's not as  ah 289 oh my god